so the advantage of inclusive wealth as
I've indicated is that it provides a
coherent and cohesive view sort of
unified prepare framework to talk about
sustainable development it is
forward-looking mean the wealth
component it's really focused on assets
and asset value asset values at least in
theory are capturing the future flow of
benefits that those assets create so
that's why this is a potentially useful
approach for looking at sustainable
development it is an extension in a
practical sense from what's in most
economic textbooks in the sense that it
focuses on really being inclusive well
in other words let's try to incorporate
all forms of assets including natural
capital so not just focused on
manufactured capital or manufactured
capital human capital but let's
incorporate natural capital as well what
about natural capital so by natural
capital I'm going to include land land
resources natural resources in the way
of mineral or energy timber fish stocks
so forth environmental quality but also
an ecosystem processes that you know if
we if we change the ecosystem structure
or function that and led to changes in
these more proximate forms of natural
capital like environmental quality so
fundamentally we have to keep track of
kind of big infrastructure of ecosystems
just as we would keep track of the
infrastructure of manufactured capital
on the human side okay unfortunately
natural capital we can you know we can
certainly track certain aspects of
natural capital so mineral resources
energy resources timber some forms of
environmental qualities of greenhouse
gas concentrations but even here of
course what we want is not the flow of
minerals and energy we really want how
is the stock of these resources changing
so I don't want to know about current
oil production as much as I want to know
out reserves of oil and there's great
uncertainty about reserves even for
things like oil which are heavily
studied fish stocks you know we have
some stock assessments there are
questions about how accurate and so
forth but so we can measure some stocks
with uncertainty but we can measure some
stocks of natural capital ecological
processes some types of Environmental
Quality the resilience of systems so if
we if we are changing systems is perhaps
subtle ways that might lead to in the
future fundamental shifts and how those
ecosystems function we try to measure
that and capture that I think that's
something right now that we are woefully
inadequate to be able to do so there's a
lack of systematic data collection
there's also frankly a lack of kind of
Ian alluded to it very early on when he
said you know what's our natural science
based understanding is it up to the task
and in some some of these things it's
clearly not up to the task at the moment
okay so going on human capital so we're
talking about education experience you
know we can at least measure how many
hours you spent in the classroom whether
that actually measures how much you know
is as a harder thing and experience it's
also hard to measure health capital
actually turns out to be if you've read
the arrow article looked at that the
2010 version their health capital
measures are hugely important and really
drive much more quantitatively important
than other forms of capital so the
changes that they look at in terms of
inclusive wealth or are really driven by
health capital considerations how should
we treat social capital or institutions
there are some measures of good
governance can we predict in the future
how much good governments there's there
will be I think the answer to there is
Brie fundamentally know who predicted
the Arab Spring prior to the beginning
of this year
how do we think about trust
relationships among people and so on so
there's a there's a lot in social
capital I think it's very difficult to
measure okay so in summary there's many
forms of capital some of which can be
measured some of which can be measured
but maybe only in precisely in some is
it going to be very difficult to get any
kind of consistent data to measure them
at all